you
[Music]
all right I think we can get started
thanks everyone for coming this is an
installment of the New York City data
science seminar series which is a
quarterly series we have between
Columbia Cornell Facebook Microsoft
Research and NYU so we have talks about
every three months and the idea is to
bring together sort of the broader data
science community I'm very happy to have
Ziad Obermeyer here he's sort of
uniquely positioned to talk about the
intersection of machine learning and
medicine because he himself is a
practicing physician who also happens to
know about as much machine learning and
statistics as most statisticians and
machine learners that have met so I'm
really glad to have him here he is
currently a associate professor at the
School of Public Health at Berkeley he
has his medical degree from Harvard
Medical School and before that he
studied history and philosophy of
science at the University of Cambridge
he has a whole bunch of distinctions and
awards and I won't embarrass him too
much by listing them all because I'm too
excited to see his talk about racial
bias and predictive healthcare so I'll
let you take it from there
thanks so much Jacob thanks for having
me just make sure I can have a leash
that's enough here I I was asking Jake
if this was gonna be an economic style
audience or a regular audience and so so
I'm used to presenting to economists
which is to say please don't hesitate to
interrupt me aggressively and often as I
talk to you about dissecting racial bias
in an algorithm so I think just by way
of introduction the the general tone of
the conversation around machine learning
and medicine is extremely optimistic and
as a disclaimer I share a lot of that
optimism I think that there are a lot of
fantastic ways that algorithms are going
to completely transform and improve
medicine at the same time I think it's
important to
be conscious of the fact that these
tools can also do harm and I do remember
taking that oath and and that's not
something we're supposed to do and so
I'm gonna tell you about one real-world
use case where I think an algorithm is
because it incorporates racial bias
actually doing some harm in society
in a way that's affecting important
decisions for millions of people and I'm
gonna tell you a little bit about the
way we diagnosed that problem which is
by by virtue of having access to a
fairly unique data set that unlike a lot
of studies of racial bias audit studies
of algorithms that are in the world that
are widely deployed we have access to a
lot of data not just about how the
algorithm works but also the the
character and the mechanisms by which
the bias gets introduced and reproduced
in that algorithm and that's of course
what lets us design a solution that'll
also be curious to get your thoughts on
so so I think if you step back and look
at this kind of again very optimistic
view of what medicine is what machine
learning is gonna do for medicine you
know on the horizon there are some
really amazing looking tools and so this
is a paper that came out in nature two
years ago that inputs a picture of
different skin findings and outputs the
probability that something is a very
serious skin problem like melanoma or
something much more benign and I think
these algorithm this is just one of many
algorithms that you know is coming and I
think these are very much going to be
part of the conversation on medicine and
as we look ahead to to how that is going
to play out you can imagine that an
algorithm that literally looks at the
color of someone's skin might run into
some problems around its performance in
different racial groups this was not
mentioned in that paper incidentally and
and so putting all that aside we're
actually going to talk about a
completely different kind of algorithm
today so it's not something that takes
in some high dimensional signal and
scrutinizes it for things that doctors
can't find this is actually
something that is already deployed very
very widely in the healthcare system and
affecting many many patients every year
and rather than a kind of medical
algorithm per se this is something
that's used in the policy context of
medicine so this is how administrators
and people who do population health
management make decisions and and the
the way to think about why now and why
this is kind of already so widely
deployed is that in the setting of the
Affordable Care Act Obamacare the
incentives set for all of the actors in
the healthcare system completely
switched and so rather than a model
where individual patients are being
treated one at a time in a
fee-for-service model and the revenues
captured through that interaction health
systems and hospitals are increasingly
incentivized to manage whole populations
of patients like at very large scale and
so you can see how that's going to be a
setting where algorithms can can
flourish and can can both add a lot of
value and do a lot of damage and so the
particular if that we're going to talk
about is targeting a particular problem
that I think everyone would agree is
pretty widespread which is how we handle
very complex patients so I think
everyone who's had any interaction with
the healthcare system knows that if you
have a simple problem
chances are things will go well if you
have multiple chronic conditions you're
on many many different medications you
have many doctors who are giving
sometimes contradictory recommendations
you have to get appointments with lots
of different specialists things go wrong
and balls get dropped and that ends up
leading to a lot of bad outcomes
emergency visits hospitalizations as
your health deteriorates and you get
kind of lost in this maddening shuffle
that in fairness is partially due to
medical complexity but also due to
administrative complexity in our
healthcare system as well and so there's
been a lot of thought over the past ten
years around how we might be able to
redesign the way these kinds of patients
interface with with the healthcare
system and improve the way that works
and so the single thing if you look kind
of across every health care system in
the u.s. almost every single one has
invested pretty heavily in what's called
care coordination programs or care
high-risk care management it goes by
lots of different names the basic idea
is that if you're one of these very high
cost high complexity patients and you
have a problem they just want you to
pick up the phone so there's a dedicated
phone number it's you can think of it a
little bit like you're you know premier
1k number or like it's just a it's a VIP
program for people who really need help
and you're incentivized to just call
whenever there's a problem so have a low
threshold for calling this number and
when you need help they'll basically
like identify problems and do the triage
and do their best to fix the problem so
there's a staff of trained nurses who
are around to kind of be the air traffic
controller so they have extra slots that
they set aside with primary care doctors
they will fill your prescription though
if you run out they'll kind of like do
all this stuff though
they'll reconcile all the prescriptions
that all of your different doctors are
giving you and make sure there aren't
interactions or kind of things that are
gonna adversely impact your health and
so overall people find these things
incredibly helpful because it's very
hard to navigate a complex medical
system and so the evidence on these
programs is generally positive in the
sense that Wow
you know some people debate how much of
an impact on kind of the bottom line
they have patients really like them and
they do seem to find health problems
before you know before they get bad and
so if you have you know if your blood
pressure gets out of control before you
go into heart failure and need to get
hospitalized they'll adjust the dose of
your medication and prevent that
hospitalization and so that's the
mechanism by which it's thought that
small problems get nipped in the bud
before they turn into big problems that
require hospitalizations and procedures
and things like that and so it just
turns out that these programs deliver
both better quality and lower
cost in a way that's good for it's good
for the patient but it's also good for
the healthcare system because it cuts
down on these burdensome high-cost
events that are also causing costs at
the healthcare system level to spiral
out of control so so you can see how
algorithms would be very useful here
because these programs are expensive so
it's like dedicated nurses like nurse
practitioners who are trained it's extra
appointment slots which is also a very
valuable commodity it's a lot of you
know it's a lot of stuff and and that
stuff is expensive and so the the
targeting of those programs is critical
you cannot do this for everyone this is
a this is a VIP Pro not everyone can be
a VIP unfortunately and so that's where
health care systems are using algorithms
to do that targeting and so you can take
these industry estimates with a grain of
salt but the industry the analytics
healthcare analytics industry estimates
that are about a hundred and fifty
million patients every year are screened
through an algorithm as part of the
decision making to target them with one
of these programs or not we're going to
be talking about the single largest one
that's being used so this alone is
estimated to be used for decision making
for 70 million people and the the goal
of these algorithms is generically as
well as this is a kind of quote taken
from the manufacturer is to target
patients with complex health needs and
to flag them for intervention before
their health becomes catastrophic and so
the specific thing that the algorithm
we're gonna study does is it's going to
look ahead to next year's costs and
predict those using data from this year
and it's going to do that largely with
insurance claims type data so this can
be from Medicare this can be from
commercial insurance but it's the the
kinds of data that are generically
available some of them use electronic
health record data but the norm is just
to use insurance claims data so you'll
stop there any questions
yeah it's usually the healthcare systems
themselves so you know like the the New
York Presbyterian accountable care
organization would buy the algorithm
from a commercial manufacturer and then
there are different arrangements that
are possible but those algorithms are
then used to generate predictions for
patients with in the NYPD system say
standardized in what way no no they're
just commercial products there's no no
there's no regulation or kind of
standardization the data used is is for
the it's not given by the hospital yes
exactly
yeah yeah because it's you're generating
predictions for your own patients yeah
maybe yeah I'm sorry yeah let me let me
I'll tell you a little bit about this
particular algorithm in a second any
other questions - yeah yeah so there I
mean there are a lot of regulations
around you know the the provision of
health insurance and what you can and
can't take into account and denying
coverage here we're largely working
within the hospital systems themselves
and so a lot of those regulations don't
apply they don't map precisely on to
this setting okay so let me um I'll tell
you a little bit about our algorithm in
particular and then please let me know
if there any more specifics I didn't
covers so this algorithm is it's trained
on a very large national data set that
belongs to the company that makes the
algorithm and so that's millions and
millions of people across the country
it's then applied to patients who are in
a primary care practice at an academic
hospital that we partnered with to study
and so all the data I'm going to show
you are from about 40,000 patients 12%
of them are black we're going to be
focusing mostly on black white cost
differences there we have results for
other races that I can tell you about
once we have the big picture
and I think what makes this dataset
unique is that we have a lot of data on
the algorithm that that are because a
lot of the algorithms that are deployed
at scale not just in health but in the
legal system and you know credit rating
etc are proprietary it's very hard to
get access to already the predictions
but the objective function the data that
goes into it all of those things are
just really hard to get and I'll just
say this as like one plug for working in
health for those of you who are you know
marginal between working in house and
working in some other high-impact social
area you know if you can convince a
healthcare system to give you access to
the data these data are just sitting on
everyone's computer system so we just
kind of asked and they were like sure so
to other people who complain about how
hard it is to get access to commercial
predictions so so how we're gonna look
at bias is is not you know there are
many different ways to look at bias and
as some recent work has shown not all of
those things can be simultaneously
satisfied so not everything not every
algorithm can be an algorithm cannot be
unbiased in all the ways that you might
want it to be unbiased and so to sort
through that we're going to focus on
maybe the most consequential result of
the algorithm which is who gets into the
program that we're interested in so
these extra help programs so we're going
to be looking at essentially that as our
as our kind of measure of bias so here's
how the algorithm is actually used in
practice every year or kind of maybe
twice a year the so that in this case
the healthcare system has bought the
software from the manufacturer and that
software lives on the healthcare systems
cluster and you know K times a year the
patients who are in the primary care
practices their data are run through
that algorithm and a risk score is
generated and so that score is then used
as a screening mechanism for who will
get into the program and so if you are
at or above the 97th percentile you are
Auto identified for enrollment and so
the
program so those people just like get
into the program and if you're between
the 55th and the 97th percentile your
data and some additional information are
presented to your primary care doctor
and that doctor is essentially in charge
of saying yes I think this person should
be in the program or should not be in
the program so there's kind of a human
in the loop for these guys between 55
and 97 and above ninety seven you're
just in and so what we're going to be
looking at specifically is for a variety
of health outcomes that we care about
the average outcome for whites
conditional on score compared to the
average outcome for blacks conditional
on that same score and I'll show you
I'll tell you a little bit more about
why we care about those outcomes in a
second so here's just some basic data
about the population we're studying you
know there are lots of people and the
one we're going to be looking at first
is you know what we're calling total
number of illnesses and so the way to
think about this is that in a given year
you'll have a bunch of encounters with a
doctor that are recorded in your you
know in the payment data so like the the
insurance company pays for a visit you
go see your doctor or you go to the ER
or you go to the hospital for a given
medical condition and there are a
certain number of chronic illnesses that
are very commonly used to measure how
sick someone is and so this is for
things like heart failure you know heart
attack diabetes things like that and
those are bundled into this you know
kind of an index and what this number
does is it just looks at in a given year
how many encounters have you had for one
or more of those basket of like bad
things that make sense and so you can
see on average black patients are sicker
than white patients that our sample what
this graph is showing you is on the
x-axis this is the the percentile of
algorithm of algorithm predicted risk
and on the y-axis is that
this is the total number of illnesses in
a given year for people at a given
percentile of the algorithm risk and on
the y-axis we've separated out black
patients versus white patients so you
can see that basically throughout the
risk distribution conditional on the
algorithm predicted score black patients
have worse health than white patients
and so that's throughout the risk
distribution to pick an arbitrary point
we can we can look at that 97th
percentile threshold so this is the
threshold where people just
automatically get put into the program
and that that threshold blacks are you
know 28% sicker on that measure of
sickness than white patients and so is
that a lot is that a little we can
actually kind of do a simulation to try
to understand what that means what the
magnitude of that bias is so what we're
gonna do is we're gonna we're gonna be
working right at the threshold and we're
gonna start with the the white patient
who's right above the threshold so this
is the person who gets kind of defaulted
into the program so we're going to take
the the least sick white patient and
we're gonna take the sickest black
patient who didn't get into the program
and we're gonna swap them and we're just
going to repeat that exercise until the
marginal patient has the same health so
we're just gonna like switch and switch
and switch until we get to people who
have the same health and if we do that
we would actually double the fraction of
auto-enrolled black patients in the
program and so this is not a this
doesn't seem like a small amount of bias
at least around this threshold and you
can see it's kind of it's fairly smooth
a tiny threshold that you could pick
okay so that's kind of a global measure
of illness in general one nice thing
about working in this electronic health
record data set is that we can get a lot
finer resolution so this is you know a
measure that's derived from like
insurance claims so who knows what's
going on in there
so we can actually start looking at
biomarkers so we actually we have access
to the patient's blood pressure over the
course of you know the the period that
we have data and if you look at the
fraction of visits in a year where
patient's blood pressure was out of
control you can look at that too as a
function of the algorithm risk score and
race and you can see that you know again
black patients much more likely to have
uncontrolled blood pressure at that
threshold the blood pressure difference
between blacks and whites correlates
with a 12% increased risk of heart
attack 8% increase risk of all-cause
mortality so again these are fairly
large blood pressure differences this is
a biomarker that Indic indexes the
degree to which your diabetes is
controlled so hemoglobin a1c again much
higher in blacks this difference at that
risk threshold correlates to a 25
increase in all cause mortality and keep
going this is lung function and we're
just going down the list of all of the
chronic illnesses for which we have
biomarkers and the electronic health
record this is you know anemia is a
marker of chronic illness in a lot of
different ways so it aggregates just
kind of sickness it declines with age
and so at that risk threshold again that
the the hematocrit difference between
blacks and whites is about the
difference you'd see after 14 years of
aging kidney function same thing that
the marginal black patient at this risk
thresholds already meets the definition
for kidney failure whereas the white
patient is is far from it so I I'll stop
there are a lot of biomarkers on which
black patients appear to be a sicker
than white patients conditional on risk
or so so I promised you mechanisms so
where is the algorithm going wrong well
one clue is where it's going right and
so here this is the same risk score
percentiles
on the x axis on the y axis is the
average cost in that same year by black
versus white patients and you can see
that those are looking pretty close and
so you know there are some small
differences here but overall these lines
are much more overlapping than any of
the lines related to health and so you
can already guess what this next graph
is going to show this is rather than
predicted risk
the x-axis this is our measure of health
so this is the number of chronic
conditions that you have again just kind
of Bend into percentiles and you can see
that whereas cost predictions are
largely overlapping for black and white
patients these curves the the cost
conditional on health curves are quite
different and so in some sense you can
think of this as just a a trade off
because of this different relationship
between costs and health for black
patients versus white patients by
definition if you are predicting cost
accurately you will not be predicting
how accurately yeah yeah this is exactly
for the next year yep okay a couple yeah
let me let me try to answer that in the
next couple of slides and then tell me
if I haven't haven't addressed it enough
so if you just run our aggression of
cost on health and a dummy for like
black and white you get this so it's
about an eighteen hundred dollar cost
difference conditional on a given level
of health you can also we have very fine
breakdowns or the kinds of costs that
are that are underlying that aggregate
cost and so you can see that black
patients not only cost less but they
actually have very different kinds of
costs so in general the things that are
much less for black patients are this is
inpatient hospitalizations outpatient
specialists is like you know your
cardiologist your psychiatrist
outpatient surgery is things like you
know carpal tunnel release injections
for knee pain and back pain and things
like that interestingly also fewer
medications so so so this is just like
generic pharmacy expenses or less on the
other hand actually blacks have higher
teachers on things like dialysis and
emergency visits and so it does that
help give you kind of like a texture of
what kinds of costs are contributing to
this yeah so it's probably not that
because all these patients are based in
Boston and they're all in the primary
care network of a single Hospital and so
it there they might go to some different
hospitals but it's pretty centralized
and the hospital tries not to have
people go out of their network probably
not probably not because it's all in the
same network so let me I have some
guesses I don't have definitive evidence
but here here are some potential drivers
of this so oh and all I should have
mentioned all these patient patients are
insured so there is either Medicare or a
pretty good commercial insurance so it's
not it's not that people are
differentially you know seeking care
because of differential insurance at the
same time even with the same insurance
especially economic status doesn't just
operate through differential insurance
coverage so there are all sorts of
financial barriers there's a lot of
co-payments even without co-payments
there's transportation costs there is a
lot of logistical stuff like people just
have annoying bosses and have jobs where
they can't get out of work for a day to
go to their appointment so so there are
just a lot of things that because
socio-economic factors are correlated
with race you know there are those
frictions that that lead to people
getting less health care on the other
hand there are also probably some direct
effects of race so there's a really
interesting randomized trial that was
done in Oakland where black patients
were recruited and they were randomly
assigned to either a white primary care
doctor or a black primary care
and then their healthcare utilization
was tracked for the next year overall
those assigned to a black primary care
doctor had 18% higher uptake of routine
primary care services so this is things
like you know vaccinations blood
pressure screenings and that was much
much higher when there was anything
involving a needle
so like vaccinations or blood draws or
things like that versus non-invasive
blood pressure measurements and this is
you know this is a randomized trial
there's no there's nothing else going on
this is just something about that
doctor-patient relationship that's
different for black patients when they
have a black primary care doctor or a
white primary care doctor and I think
that adds to evidence that was
observational but but really compelling
around health care use by black patients
before versus after the revelations of
the Tuskegee study and further away or
closer to Tuskegee itself and there were
just enormous drops in aggregate
utilization of medical care by black
patients after after the study was
revealed and so I think these are if I
had to guess about the mechanisms this
is probably the the two big categories
of things that I would that I had put
forward okay so to summarize so far
because the algorithm is predicting cost
accurately it is under predicting health
risk
for black patients which means that
since that algorithm is used to screen
for entrance into a program it basically
means that healthier whites are kind of
cutting in line they are getting ahead
of less healthy black patients for this
extra help program and so the proximal
cause is of course the choice to predict
costs as the target yeah
yeah yeah you know I were actually like
that was a reviewer comment and and so
we're so thank you we're actually trying
to build that in now the the short the
short answer is that there are small
differences in how doctors treat black
and white patients that actually redress
the inequalities in the algorithm and so
and so black patients are getting into
the program at slightly higher rates
than they would if it were just based on
algorithm score alone it does not appear
to make up for the the bias introduced
by the screening procedure itself okay
so that's the proximal cause but of
course the deeper cause is pretty
interesting too which is why was cost
chosen as the target for the for the
prediction so there's a I think an
obvious story that I'll just caricature
for now and then we'll kind of go into
it a little bit more deeply but that
story you could call the follow the
money of story and that is that you know
sure as a society we care about health
but hospitals and insurers might
cynically privately care about just
costs and so actually that is the object
of interest for the people who pay for
health care and deliver healthcare and
in fact this is a version of a very
pervasive problem in health care which
arises from that difference so the
choice of you know costs in this case is
privately optimal but socially
suboptimal and so you could view this as
in some ways a that the prediction
equivalent of an externality which is
that that you know this difference is
not being priced in and so a private
actor is behaving in a way that the
storts a socially valuable outcome one
of many
in healthcare and so you can translate
that into a thought experiment which is
to actually as distasteful as it may be
to put yourself in the shoes of a
self-interested algorithm developer and
an imagine that actually you might be
cynically
making a trade off so you might be
willing to tolerate a certain amount of
racial bias and your predictions because
you're getting better predictions of
cost and maybe cost savings and so
that's one that's certainly one
possibility so we're gonna do a thought
allograph ad experiment where we're
gonna try to construct an algorithm that
achieves those goals as well as the
original algorithm but as less biased
and so here's what we do
we very slightly modify the original
algorithm which is to say first we rank
by health so those bins of health and in
last year and then we ranked by
predicted costs so so we're basically in
a bin of last year's health we're
ranking people by their predicted
algorithm score and then we're using
that to create a relationship in a
training set and applying that
relationship to a holdout set so I'll
show you the holdout results but this
isn't it's clumsy but it's not over fit
and here's what we get so the original
algorithm so this is a cost versus
percentile of algorithm risk score the
dark blue line is the new algorithm the
the lighter blue line is the adjusted
algorithm you can see that it's actually
predicting cost pretty well and in fact
the r-squared is quite similar but the
new algorithm is substantially less
biased so this is the percentile of the
risk score starting at 50 this is the
fraction of black patients at or above a
given score and so at the 50th
percentile and above you're getting
you're getting more black patients in
you know that would be screened into the
program throughout that part of the
distribution and if the 97th percentile
again to pick that arbitrary point there
are 61% more black patients at or above
that score under this slightly modified
rhythm than the original one and so what
we did of course was we changed in a way
you can think about it as just changing
the objective function so rather than
pure cost prediction we're almost we're
kind of blending cost and health
prediction in a very simple way that
reduces bias and it doesn't seem to
really hurt cost prediction I don't
think this is a general claim clearly
cost prediction beats not cost
prediction in general but all this is to
say that you know there are other
algorithms that we might have used that
would behave similarly and be less
biased which of course brings up the
question of what why didn't the
algorithm developer do this to which I'd
ask you why does so many online ad
algorithms predict ad clicks instead of
predicting you know revenue attributable
to the ad yeah okay and so here's here's
one hypothesis which is that we've been
thinking of one trade-off in this space
which is it's possible that the
algorithm developer is just trading off
racial bias in predictions for accuracy
of predictions and costs but there's
actually another trade-off here which I
think is the more relevant one which is
prediction accuracy versus the cost of
producing an algorithm that has a given
accuracy so and by that I don't just
mean accuracy for predicting costs you
can actually imagine that cost in year T
plus 1 is not really the object that we
even care about so you might care about
the capitalized cost of a given patient
over the period in which that patient is
likely to be in your pool of patients
that you're responsible for and even
better one might be not the cost itself
but actually the avoidable cost so if I
allocated this patient to this program
what would be my cost savings by
treating health conditions that wouldn't
otherwise be treated without that
program
and so you can tell by how many uses of
the subjunctive it's not the subject
that these are very hard objects to
produce so this is fundamentally a kind
of fairly complex heterogeneous
treatment effect question this is trying
to figure out who's going to be in my
pool in year t plus 1 D plus 2 the costs
associated with the health kit so all of
these things are actually quite
difficult to produce and if you're a
data science team you might well say
yeah we're not going to do that we're
just gonna predict costs because all
these other things are just really hard
and so my second hypothesis that I would
submit to you is not evil genius profit
maximizing corporate greed it's actually
just that this stuff is kind of hard
even come even evil corporate you know
greed doesn't produce infinite resources
for generating algorithms and so the the
operative process here is actually that
these teams are just learning how to do
this well yeah yeah
don't think health status is a better
proxy for that then cost in the future
is yeah yeah I agree and let me let me
show you one thing and and I that I
think is is exactly your point here's
the the general version of it though is
that the costs that the algorithm was
originally predicting are actually a
proxy for some underlying kind of
complex target that you know we can we
can think of lots of different ways to
specify that but it's something related
to health and I think that's to your
point the program operates on health the
program doesn't just like dial down
costs the program is fundamentally a
health intervention it's about getting
you appointments and getting you
medications and so whatever we're
interested in it's something about
health now using cost to proxy for
health is in many ways very logical
because people with more health needs do
on average have more health costs so
that actually makes a lot of sons and
it's a lot easier to measure like if you
have a data set of insurance claims data
as TRAI snows it is a lot use it since
Reyes did the original work as one of
our RS it is a lot easier to get cost
than any of these other things that he
had to wrangle out of the electronic
health record data set and so in this
view cost was chosen not because of a
privately optimal trade-off of my bias
versus you know health prediction but
just because it was pretty convenient
and because we didn't really think ahead
to the consequences of that choice yeah
you mean this hypothesis or yeah yes so
we talked to them and I'll come back to
that in a second okay
but but first but first I want to try to
make the case that this is this is not
just a particular problem affecting this
individual algorithm or even this space
of population health management
algorithms this is actually a very very
generic problem in health but but also
in social policy more broadly as salon
has actually I think started to show in
a number of really interesting articles
so in general health algorithms but but
algorithms being used in policy more
broadly are basically complex data set
in and label out and so in medicine it's
like an x-ray reading through a
convinent producing a radiologists
interpretation of that x-ray in our
setting its patient's medical history as
embodied in insurance claims data
predict cost the formulation of that
problem what is the label means that the
choice of label is often done
expediently rather than
of a deep careful knowledge and infinite
resources to pursue whatever deep
careful process is being undertaken but
that set of choices means that along
with the rest of the stuff we're
interested in we can end up automating
error and bias and incentives and
inequalities and all of the things that
we actually don't like about our
healthcare system along with the good
and so when you're automating a
radiologists interpretation of an image
you have to remember that radiologists
have incentives to behave in ways that
are not necessarily socially optimal
when you're operating with costs or
diagnosis you have to remember that
there are structural reasons for which
poor non-white people are less able to
access diagnostic resources less able to
take a day off work to get the tests
that they need to get something
diagnosed and so a generic way to think
about this is that you have a target
variable that you're predicting and that
target variable is some sum of Y star
which is the the true but unobservable
underlying quantity of interest plus
some Delta now of course we don't
observe how much is Y star and how much
is Delta so we predict Y and if your
predictor is any good the expected value
is just going to be the sum of those two
terms the expected value of y star given
X and the expected value of the Delta
given X and that gives rise to two
potential scenarios one is the good news
which is that if that Delta is basically
random that's great and you're actually
going to do better in your prediction
then in your and your observed variable
which is an amazing trick so so
essentially this is going to be your
prediction y hat is going to be a
denoise version of the thing that you
really want to predict and that's really
cool the downside is that if Delta is
not white noise you're gonna get in your
prediction the sum of those two things
and what you're going to get depends on
early on the balance of the predictable
element of Y star plus the predictable
element of Delta now we might worry
about this because in general I think
you'd agree that this is all just about
finding covariance so the covariance of
Delta with X actually has scope to be a
lot bigger than the covariance of Y star
with X why is that well because Y star
is often really complicated it's a
biological phenomenon it's overall
health it's avoidable health whatever it
is it's pretty complicated whereas the
Delta can be all too simple related to
age or insurance or race or sex or any
of the things that you know we often
record in our demographic variable set
that also affects a lot of the the
problem that create a lot of the
problems in our healthcare system and so
there are a couple general insights that
I'll just go through in the last few
minutes that that stem from this very
simple framework one is that when you're
evaluating how good your predictions are
so if we just take a simple loss
function the difference between Y star
and Y is basically the covariance but
the difference between these two things
so you can write it as the Y hat star
minus y star and Delta hat minus Delta
now imagine two algorithms a and B and a
is actually better as measured by you
know whatever loss function you're using
but let's take this one is that
predicting better because it's fitting
better to the signal or to the error and
so you actually when you're evaluating
the quality of your predictions even
your loss function is going to mislead
you in these settings because predictors
that fit two errors can look very very
good and predictors that remove Delta
from your predictions could look very
bad on whatever loss function you're
using and that's very dangerous because
it means that it's impossible to
diagnose the problem with your algorithm
the other general insight is that if you
believe that this term ends up being
nonzero you're going to end up Janell
directly reinforcing inequalities that
already exists so in a lot of problems
where we want to apply machine learning
in Social Policy and in health we're
trying to allocate resources as a
function of y hat that's just a generic
prediction policy task and whether
that's diagnostic effort or whether
that's policy is in our case for helping
hide need patients you're gonna end up
allocating more so those who have more
to begin with and so this is another
very generic problem that that stems
from this framework okay so your
question about how we got some insight
into the process I'll tell you a little
bit about the epilogue to this story
this might have been very obvious to you
but it was not obvious to us which is
that we were you know we kind of were
finishing up the paper and getting ready
to submit it and we've started thinking
that we should probably let the
manufacturer know and it was a little
bit scary because you know we had an IRB
and and we checked all of the data use
agreement stuff beforehand but you know
you never know what's gonna happen
but on the other hand we also just felt
like to start a productive conversation
doing that in the headlines first is
probably not the way to impact so we
just thought we just emailed them and we
were like hey you don't know us but we
found this thing with your algorithm and
this is like a very this is a big
company this is like an insurance
company that owns the analytics company
and so it was a little bit scary and
then in a couple of hours we got an
email back and they were like wow
this sounds like something we should
talk about and so of course the first
thing they did was they got their data
science team to make sure that what we
found was also in their data which it
was so they replicated the results on
there you know one of their data sets
that they used to build the algorithm
and then their response was like can you
help us fix this and so they just wanted
to work with us and figure out how to
make this better which is really cool
and so
we are in collaboration with the
manufacturer I should say this also came
up in the review process I have no
conflicts of interest we're not getting
any money from the manufacturer they
didn't have any control over what we did
in fact this started off as a project to
try to estimate heterogeneous treatment
effects from those discontinuities and
the score didn't work out but that's why
we originally got the data and so we're
working with that manufacturer to
develop methods to essentially predict a
basket of health outcomes rather than
just predicting cost and this is early
days but by a very simple fix to that
algorithm on this measure of bias which
is essentially at a given score how many
excess conditions do you have across the
whole risk distribution and blacks
versus whites this was in their data set
the number of excess conditions and
black patients and on the adjusted
algorithm there are 84 percent fewer of
those so at least by that kind of
rudimentary measure we're doing a lot
better I think I saw someone had a
question yeah weirdly these are
completely unregulated so there are no
applicable regulations that you would
invoke - no no no it's I mean it's um
it's I agree with you it's surprising
this is a very it's a very unregulated
space right now and the FDA is
essentially not not being very proactive
about getting out in front of the way
that a lot of algorithms are being used
in Health for specific medical purposes
like interpreting x-rays I think they're
actually much better but for these kinds
of complex decision making processes
there are no regulations that you would
invoked
signals and yeah yeah it's a great
question I think that's also probably a
convenience decision so these are if you
had to pick a single kind of data that
are available at every single you know
organization that pays for health care
its claims data many healthcare systems
don't have their electronic health
records up online and in a way that's
easily accessible without trace to help
so yeah it's also a choice driven by
convenience other questions okay so I
think overall the the way ID code all of
this is to say that once you recognize
that you're your choice of proxy is just
that you can actually start learning how
to make that better and I think that's
to your point yeah I think there are a
lot of things that have much less
measurement error for the thing that we
care about than cost that are not as
easy as cost because there's some data
cleaning involved and there's you know
there's stuff to do but I think that
that to me makes that learning view more
plausible than the kind of privately
optimal profit maximization view so just
say to end a couple of things about that
and modified algorithm with reference to
some of the literature on the mechanisms
of bias and algorithm so there are a
couple of things that are worth pointing
out the training data are exactly the
same so this is not a problem that there
are not enough non-white people in the
training data this is the same training
data same composition nothing different
and the predictors are also the same so
we did not have to take race out of the
predictor in fact race was never
included in the original predictor as we
learned when we were talking to them
precisely because they didn't want to
create any racial bias in their
algorithm and and and we did not do
anything like orthogonal izing all of
the x's again like nothing the only
thing we changed
was the target of prediction and if you
think back to the measurement error
framework once you take the Delta out
there's nothing for the X's to Co vary
with and so the only thing it's going to
Co vary with is y star not Delta and so
I think that's a it's an obvious point
ex-post
but I think it's actually for me a
really optimistic view of ways in which
you can do something about racial bias
without having access to more data
collection without needing to do a lot
of stuff to the set of predictors it's
really focusing on that choice of the
label
okay so just the clothes we found quite
a bit of racial bias in a fairly widely
used commercial algorithm at the same
risk score blacks were less healthy and
thus were less likely to get into this
extra help program for their health and
the root cause of that was cost
prediction rather than some more complex
health prediction and while it's easy to
see how the the original algorithm
reinforced structural inequalities where
patients who used more care would then
be allocated to get more care the the
modified algorithm doesn't solve any of
those problems we're not doing anything
about the structural inequalities here
unfortunately but the fix to the
algorithm is built on an understanding
of those forces and how they play out in
data and I think that that's really for
me the the secret to working to reverse
them is starting with that awareness so
I'll stop there I don't know if we have
time for questions but very happy to
take more
[Applause]
it's not potential and now it will lead
to a question about data so if the boys
from blacks is lower there will be an
incentive for insurance companies to
prefer to pay more complex and therefore
they would encourage more blacks
yeah on the other hand the doctors seem
to prefer wise because the insurance
pays more money for the same procedures
so they would try to get more White's
into their practice there are less
because the insurance doesn't pay enough
so they have this conflict of interests
hmm
now if you would collect the price and
make it the same for blacks and whites
would it algorithm that if you know how
could it work in the same way and give
the same results as you come up with
when you sort by help so you think that
yeah yeah yeah the insurance versus dr.
Kaplan's and has nothing to do with
algorithm itself yep yeah and I think
that it seems like if I understand your
question correctly if the cost
production function from how for the
same for blacks and whites we would not
have a problem we probably wouldn't have
a problem and I think that echo is a lot
you know many of the the work on kind of
generic bias and algorithm is that you
know if the base rates of the outcome
are the same and the in the different
groups then that's the that's kind of a
that's the secret is to fix the fix the
structural inequalities so I think that
in some ways I should think more about
the conflict of interest point the
reason it's a little bit I think you're
right that there should be an incentive
to cherry-pick black patients because in
this setting what happens is the the
health system is paid a flat fee per
patient and then if they do less for
those patients they keep the change
whereas if they end up having to do more
for patients they
you know they lose money and so your
ideal patient if you were
profit-maximizing would be a patient who
had a lot of diagnosis codes that you
could use to say to the government look
how sick they are but didn't actually
use any healthcare and so you're right
that as a health system they should be
preferring to get these sicker but less
likely to utilize patients of which more
seem to be black and I don't know I
don't know if that's something that
happens in real life yeah yeah great
question so I think in general one of
one of the fixes to bias that are that
that's proposed in literature or the
diagnosis is we haven't learned the the
relationship for the minority group and
so we actually need to not just kind of
bootstrap which wouldn't fix as you say
it wouldn't fix that problem but you
need to go collect more data and get new
new examples of of that study it you
learn that relationship better
interesting estimating heterogeneous
treatment effects but they like you know
decided practically that even though
it's what we wanted to do you would
content ourselves with this or was it
something that you sort of inferred from
your discussion I'm just kind of curious
how explicitly they engage this kind of
way off straight off yeah yeah I think
that on the one hand a big priority for
this company is investing and helping
their clients to get electronic health
record data up and running and so I
think that on the one hand I think
they're quite interested in enriching
the data I think that they probably
would have framed a little bit
differently than this so I think that
there is not just at this company but
just it's worth pointing out also that
the
you you know it's something that I've
been saying company but the user of this
algorithm is a non-profit academic
health system and so this is not just
the mentality that's in the company this
is like a but the dominant mentality is
cost prediction because cost is just
this very salient variable to lots of
people in the healthcare system
and the assumption you know to your
question about are they thinking about
how to a genius treatment effects no not
at all like not at all there is just
this very dominant assumption that the
cost reductions are proportional and so
they would they would say it's it's what
the the quote of like why do you rob
banks well that's where the money is
it's like why do you why do you want to
get these high-cost patients into the
program well that's where the cost
savings are and the idea that the actual
treatment effects are not proportional
to the - why is a foreign idea in this
world so I'd say you know long-winded
answer but I think it's mixed I don't
think that their explicit plan would
have been to come up with better
measures that are closer to the real
quantity of interest things like Oh
obviously we should have done this or
was it something that they were like oh
we've never would have thought of this
this is completely different than the
way we approach the problem I think it
was let's try it and then when that
reduced the degree of bias
I think ex-post it it just makes sense
yeah
feels very much in the flavour of some
of the work that came out of the
recidivism scores on that yeah yeah and
if we just imagine that there's a binary
desirable outcome here which is that the
person gets healthier then it feels like
there might be a disparity between the
false negative rates like that could be
another way to reframe the science yeah
the expected Y given yep race and health
that you put up it seems like an you
know analog to that is that yeah I'm
just curious if after all this even
though you approached the solution a
different way if you actually do end up
getting you know equalized yeah it's
interesting I mean I think I'd need to
think about this and I can't think this
fast so I need to write it out but I
think I think that the fact that we have
this calibration on this is one of these
things that can't be simultaneously
satisfied so if you condition on the
outcome and then look back and want
equality that measure of bias is
incompatible with these calibrations
genre measures and so I think that that
is a that is just an algebraic trade-off
that that wouldn't go away and so I
think you just you know you you couldn't
have both of those things so I don't
know which direction if you can if you
wanted equal numbers of black and white
in the false negative group or something
like that I'm not sure how that would
actually work in this data set
and if the goal is to use it clearly was
not achieving that because maybe like
just to be completely objective in
fundraise does use yeah health care less
maybe that this does reduce yeah no it's
an important question and I think you
know there there is probably a true
underlying trade-off here in the sense
that you can't do everything for
everyone and you know there might well
be true underlying differential
predictability of Y star by race and if
there is then I think that brings up
exactly the trade-offs that you that you
posed I think that we're almost tackling
a smaller problem which is to say that
sure there might be some underlying true
difference between blacks and whites but
we're not even close to Y star here Y
star is probably something like you know
to your point that about the treatment
effects so if I targeted a person with
this program how much money would I save
for what it's worth just I won't go back
but when you look at the breakdown of
costs by race black patients have more
spending on emergency visits and that is
exactly the kind of stuff that the
program is meant to work against so if I
had to predict which way it would go if
we could approach that true underlying
quantity of interest I know actually
probably disproportionately favored
blacks and so and so anyway all that is
to say that I think the closer we get to
the real underlying quantity that the
prediction target the more the real
trade-offs kick in but we're so far from
the optimal now that I think there's a
lot of room to just make you know
improvements on many different margins
still out in the back and you can grab
him for questions that you didn't get to
ask and I'll grab beer
[Applause]